le gland de lait vous connaissez bah de
la même manière qu'on a des dents de
lait le glandais c'est le petit bout de
chair provisoire que les enfants ont au
bout du pénis à la puberté il tombe de
lui-même ou alors on l'arrache on
l'accrochant à une ficelle elle-même
attachée à une poignée de porte vous
connaissez sûrement truc et puis la
forme définitive retouche on appelle ça
le glandes sagesse alors est-ce que ça
existe vraiment mais non pas du tout
c'est une légende urbaine je dis ça sans
jugement mais je dis ça très
sérieusement parce que j'ai vu passer
plein de questions là-dessus il y a des
gens qui y croient vraiment le gland de
lait ça n'existe pas donc pour que les
choses soient bien claires read my lips
le gland de lait ça n'existe pas
imaginez la gueule de la petite